Humans can survive in this universe as long as we have an energy source.
Unfortunately the universe will die.
It will happen slowly over many billions of years,
but it will happen on a universal timescale.
Stars like our Sun will be gone in no time.
Luckily,
there are places that will exist practically forever.
From a human perspective,
the corpse is of dead stars,
white dwarves.
They could be.
Humanity is lost home right before the death of the universe.
What are these strange things and what happens when they finally die?
How Long Stars live varies drastically depending on how massive they are.
For example,
really massive stars burn hot and fast dying violently in Supernova a few
million years after birth,
but they're the exception.
97% of all stars will end their existence as white dwarfs.
There are two ways this can happen.
Small stars,
so called a red dwarfs burnout over trillions of years until they eventually
quietly turn into white toffs medium size stars like our sun are more
interesting.
Imagine the sun as a huge pressure cooker that fuses hydrogen into helium and
it's called through its gravity.
The fusion of relevance releases extreme amounts of energy that pushes outwards
and stabilizes the star.
Keeping it in a delicate balance.
When the sun is old,
the hydrogen and the core is exhausted and the sun will begin to burn helium and
to heavier elements while doing so,
it will shat its outer layers.
When this process is over,
more than half of the sun's mass will be lost into space as a spectacular
planetary Nebula,
millions of kilometers to cross.
What remains will be its former core oh white 12 is born a star corpse.
What its former self was about 100 times its diameter.
Now it's only about as big as earth,
but still with about half of its format.
This means it's extremely dense.
A teaspoon of white dwarf is about as massive as a car it surface.
Gravity is over 100,000 times higher than us.
If you tried to land on it,
you'd immediately be compressed into a steaming puddle.
Life around a white dwarf is very unlikely,
but possible.
Most of them that exist.
Now we're former stars that Welch died,
which probably ruined any panics they once hat,
but that's not all.
Since they are so small,
a planet would need to orbit them about 75 times closer than earth is to the sun
to have liquid water.
There's proximity has up and downsides.
For one,
it would tidally locked the punish,
giving it a permanent day and permanent night
at the edges of these day and night zones.
Life could be possible,
but white dwarves have a very stable energy output,
so they might actually be safer to live around them.
Many red dwarfs.
This is still speculation at this point,
but if we could find a white wolf with the right conditions to settle around,
we could have a home for many billions of years,
but why do they shine so much longer than other star types?
White dwarfs are very,
very hot,
up to 40 times hotter than our sun ranking among the hottest objects in the
universe that they are not incredibly active.
All the heat inside of them is trapped and has nowhere to go.
Only on its outer layer can escape into space,
but space is mostly empty so he'd can't be transferred by conduction.
The only way energy can escape is by radiation.
This is so inefficient that white dwarves.
We'll take trillions of years to cool down which may make them humanity's last
refuge.
They might be the last sources of light and energy in a dying universe.
According to some estimates,
white dwarves might shine as long as 100 billion,
billion years,
10 billion times longer than the universe has existed so far into the future
that no regular stars will sign any anymore.
Galaxies will have evaporated and only then will the first white dwarf turn into
the first black dwarf.
When this happens,
the last hope for life will die off land offs will be inactive fairs with no
energy left to give still massive enough to kill you.
If you get too close,
so cold that there'll be near the cold is possible.
Temperature in the universe so dark that they are practically invisible.
The universe will enter its last stage heat death,
which we'll leave the universe unrecognizable and absolutely dark and cold
graveyard with a black holes and black dwarves scattered over trillions of light
years.
We don't know for sure what will happen with black dogs in the end.
If the Proton,
one of the fundamental parts of atoms has a limited lifespan,
blank dwarfs will slowly evaporate over many trillions of years.
If the Proton does not decay,
black doors will probably turn into spheres of pure iron via quantum tunneling
over a time span,
so obscenely gigantic that calling it forever is okay.
These irons fairs will then travel completely alone through a dark universe.
Nothing new will happen anymore forever.
While this may sound kind of dark,
this is set far away that for our purposes today,
it might as well not happen at all.
It doesn't matter what happens in a billion,
trillion years right now,
we happen to exist at an excellent time,
able to be an or about a universe filled with endless stars and light and planet
and enough time to visit them.
One day
I'm music is finally available on Spotify and iTunes.
It's composed by our good friends at epic mountain.
Two guys with a studio who make music for a living.
You can check them out here and follow them on Facebook and Twitter,
and if you like our videos,
please consider supporting us on Patriot.
It really would be extremely helpful if you need an excuse to delay work a
little bit longer.
Here's a playlist with more space videos.